die cdu käme auf die um rentner kann man
sagen die preview ist eigentlich keine
partie erst wähler waren er verletzt
bereit wie immer kurz vor der wahl
versucht sich die politik würdelos an
die jugendlichen rand zu schmeißen mal
sehen wie viel die politiker wirklich
von den jugendlichen wissen
los gehts letzte genau können wir
vielleicht mal ein ziel ihrer parteien
einen satz nämlich über westermann für
die jugendlichen eine übersetzung ich
mache das radeln her zu finden
wir wollen dass europa sich nun die
dinge konzentriert die vergehen europa
gelöst werden müssen natürlich um jeden
gramm vor ort eine zeit gab es war der
profi jung ist erwächst bankett die csu
ist nichts für euch ist nicht super cool
ist nicht gut die wahl ob sie die coolen
abkürzung der kids camp wissen die was
lol bedeutet
und lieber ohne das auto lauf richtig
man macht heutzutage immer sehr tief
damit sie uns helfen die grille auch an
lassen sich auch jetzt gerade du heißt
ehrlicher haben sich als 18 jähriger
schütze politik interessiert haben
wieder gar keine front oder auszuloten
ich bin schon familiär vorbelastet er
keine papas hätten die dann gewählt wenn
du jemals jungen gewesen bin glücklicher
weil ich die partei gut finde ich nicht
sehr früh kurzem entschieden dass eine
frage die vor allem unsere jungen
zuschauer interessiert sind wie viel
mehr oder viel weniger pornografie im
internet für viele interessant sei dass
die dagegen seine reichweite sind alles
sehr diese begrifflichkeiten aus der
twitter fans behaupten
also ich spreche gerne französisch
englisch rock folk ordnung wird dann die
richtige partei die cdu kümmert sich um
rentner kann man sagen die cdu es
eigentlich keine partei verstellbaren er
verletzt wenn man über die auch nicht
lustig machen diese zu und versteht
eingeschlagen und jetzt der letzte der
es eigentlich nix ein obwohl ich kenne
ich natürlich klar im lager kommt ja
damit sind doch alle fragen geklärt nur
eine frage bleibt noch offen was
bedeutet eigentlich mit jan ich denke
dass mit der wasg - einfach mal sagen
kann mit bedeutet natürlich magath